the great Danny DeVito he joined the
cast was it season 2 that he joined the
cast yes
- yeah and what is what does he bring to
the show because he's fantastic on the
show I can say why yeah it is the rest
of you it feels very much like you're of
a piece and then there's Danny DeVito
who's in the show and it works it works
friendly he's he's hilariously funny his
characters fantastic it all works but
you wonder how did you how'd you get
Danny DeVito we still ask ourselves that
question and him almost every day like
why would you why are you doing this had
such a great career yeah I think we have
a still of Danny from the Daria's does
he ever say no does he ever say I'm not
doing it I draw the line
he loves doing the show yeah and he
loves being apart and he really has done
crazy things he's jumped out of a couch
naked before and we asked me to do it I
think this last season was the first
time he ever was like we wanted him to
be he was stuck in a coil in a
playground yeah yeah and we wanted him
to be in his underwear
actually we wanted to be naked but we
thought like in his underwear it would
be funny and we want to be in tighty
whities and he came to set in boxer
briefs and I came up to him and I was
like hey Danny I really want you to be
you know your tighty whiteys just
funnier he finally relented but his one
condition was that I put them on him
[Applause]
and I think we have a whole clip we have
a clip the way yeah oh it's good let's
take a look Charlie put you want put the
things on the black shorts don't work
[Applause]
don't linger on it don't you can you be
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go
[Applause]
then if there were children in the
background